.
Zucker - speziell am Zucker ist,
dass wir alle wissen,
dass er ungesund ist.
Aber trotzdem sind wir nicht bereit,
das zu glauben.
Es ist unglaublich.
Alles schnelle Essen
und Trinken enthält Zucker.
Die Süssgetränkeindustrie
hat eine Lobby
und ist im Parlament vertreten,
selbst in der Gesundheitskommission
des Nationalrats.
Das finde ich absolut verwerflich.
Wenn man einem Kind sagt:
"Das ist nicht für dich,
das enthält Alkohol",
dann wirkt das fürsorglich.
Wenn wir das mit Zucker machen,
sind wir gemein.
Zucker ist für mich eine Sucht.
Der Staat subventioniert den Zucker.
Derselbe Staat gibt wiederum
unsere Steuergelder aus,
um die Bevölkerung aufzuklären,
dass wir nicht zu viel von diesem
weissen Zeug konsumieren sollen.
Das ist absolut schizophren.
Mit Untertiteln
von SWISS TXT
"Liebe Redaktion."
"Wir möchten uns für die Teilnahme
an der Zucker-Challenge bewerben."
"Wir sind eine fünfköpfige Familie
aus Döttingen AG."
"Unsere Kinder
sind zwischen 14 und 18 Jahre alt."
"Über Zucker
haben wir schon oft diskutiert."
"Die Versuche,
den Zucker zu reduzieren,
scheiterten an Pralines,
Bärentatzen, Panettoni."
"Wir sind nicht alle überzeugt,
dass wir
ein solches Experiment durchstehen."
"Aber wir wären hoch motiviert,
es zu versuchen."
"Herzliche Grüsse,
Familie Rechsteiner."
Zucker ist für mich
schon relativ wichtig.
V.a. zwischendurch als Aufmunterung,
oder wenn ich gestresst bin,
brauche ich etwas Süsses.
Es ist eine Herausforderung
und es ist interessant.
Man merkt dann erst so richtig:
Boah, es ist überall Zucker drin!
Ich habe das auch
in der Klasse erzählt.
Alle haben mich
komisch angeschaut und gesagt:
"Du, du isst so viel Zucker!
Das wirst du nie schaffen."
Aber ich werde ihnen beweisen,
dass ich das kann.
Es ist schwierig, auf die Kekse
am Abend zu verzichten.
Noch nie ausprobiert.
Ich hoffe,
dass der Bauch etwas zurückgeht.
Dass ich vielleicht
noch 1,2 kg abnehmen kann.
Ja, ich hoffe, dass ich dann beim
Joggen weniger schwer atmen muss.
Das wäre für mich
die Belohnung dieses Monats.
Du kannst Nature-Joghurt essen.
Wahrscheinlich
geht die Migros Pleite,
wenn wir das nicht mehr kaufen.
Vor 150 Jahren
war Zucker ein Luxusgut.
Der Zuckerkonsum in der Schweiz
lag pro Tag und Person bei
zwei Zuckerwürfeln, also etwa 8 g.
Mit der Industrialisierung
wurde Zucker
zum billigen Kalorienlieferanten.
Damit stieg der Verbrauch rapide.
Heute konsumiert ein Erwachsener
im Durchschnitt über 100 g pro Tag,
doppelt so viel, wie die Welt
gesundheitsorganisation empfiehlt.
Laut dem Bundesamt für Gesundheit
ist Fettleibigkeit auch in der
Schweiz zur Volkskrankheit geworden.
42 % der Erwachsenen in der Schweiz
sind übergewichtig.
Jedes sechste Kind ist zu dick.
Ein Grossteil
der ernährungsbedingten Krankheiten
kommt durch den zu hohen Konsum von
Zucker zustande - Tendenz steigend.
Sophie Stirnimann
ist diplomierte Ernährungsberaterin.
Sie wird Familie Rechsteiner
beim Zuckerverzicht
beraten und unterstützen.
Ihr habt mir die letzten Wochen
fleissig Essprotokolle geschrieben.
Damit habe ich berechnet,
wie viel Zucker jeder von euch
an einem durchschnittlichen Tag
konsumiert.
Obwohl hier alle überzeugt sind,
im Alltag nicht übermässig Zucker
zu konsumieren,
zeigt die Auswertung
der Essprotokolle ein anderes Bild.
Ein Schweizer konsumiert
je nach betrachteter Quelle
durchschnittlich 28 Würfelzucker.
Das sind ca. 110 g pro Tag.
Den niedrigsten Konsum hatte ...
... Esther.
- Ah.
Und zwar mit 13 Würfelzucker.
Pro Tag?
- Pro Tag.
Den zweitniedrigsten Konsum
in eurer Familie hatte Antonia.
In der goldenen Mitte warst du,
Sybille.
Die beiden, die bei euch
den meisten Zucker konsumieren,
wussten es im Voraus schon.
Stellt sich nur noch die Frage,
wer Erster und wer Zweiter ist.
Ihr seid beide genau gleich hoch.
20 Würfelzucker,
die etwa 80 g entsprechen.
Aber wir sind
immer noch unter dem Durchschnitt.
Wir sind unter dem Durchschnitt,
aber wenn ich denke,
dass ich das
alles weglassen muss ...
... und zwar pro Tag.
Gut, für eure Herausforderung:
Wenn ihr
ganz auf Zucker verzichten wollt,
sind diese Würfel
die nächsten vier Wochen tabu.
Ich wünsche euch für den Monat
viel Erfolg und toi, toi, toi.
Vielen Dank.
- Also, weg damit.
* Akzentuierte Klänge *
Ärztin Bettina Wölnerhanssen
forscht vorwiegend zu den Themen
Übergewicht
und Alternativen zum Zucker.
Um festzustellen, was der
Zuckerverzicht im Körper bewirkt,
hat sie im Vorfeld
mit Familie Rechsteiner
verschiedene Tests durchgeführt.
Wir haben den Blutzucker, das
Insulin, die Blutfette gemessen
und das Gewicht bestimmt.
Man sieht, dass das Blutfett,
der Blutzucker und das Insulin
bei allen tendenziell
etwas erhöht sind.
Ob sich das
in dieser kurzen Zeit verbessert -
mal schauen, könnte sein.
Ich bin gespannt,
ob sie es durchziehen.
Es ist schon recht streng.
Wir haben ihnen
sehr strenge Regeln auferlegt.
Klar ist, dass v.a. frische
und unverarbeitete Lebensmittel
auf der Positivliste stehen.
Zuckeraustauschstoffe
wie Erythrit, Stevia
oder Birkenzucker sind erlaubt.
Neben offensichtlich
zuckerhaltigen Esswaren
muss auch auf Fertigprodukte
verzichtet werden.
Obwohl diese nicht süss schmecken,
steckt meistens
versteckter Zucker drin.
Die Zucker-Challenge beginnt.
Schon das Einkaufen
ist eine Herausforderung.
80 % aller Lebensmittel
enthalten Zucker.
Oh, Kaffee wäre nicht schlecht.
Denkst du, einer von denen wäre gut?
Schau sie dir an.
- Moment.
Cappuccino - was enthält er?
Hier stehen die Nährwerte
und die Zutatenliste.
(Esther)
Zucker - da ist Zucker drin.
8,5 g.
- Etwas mehr.
Ich glaube, das lohnt sich nicht.
Ich stelle ihn zurück.
Doch lieber frisch Gemachter.
- Ja, das ist so.
Wo geht es weiter?
Wir brauchen noch eine
Müeslimischung für das Frühstück.
Die sieht doch gut aus.
Es steht darauf:
"Mit Reissirup gesüsst."
Sie enthält auch
19 g Zucker von 63 Kohlenhydraten.
Ausserdem 63 g Kohlenhydrate.
Ja, stellen wir sie
auch wieder zurück.
Es werden Alternativen angepriesen,
die gar keine sind.
Z.B. Dattel-,
Ahorn- oder Agavensirup.
Das sind keine Alternativen.
Das sind auch Zuckerprodukte -
einfach in einer anderen Form.
Wenn man über Alternativen sprechen
will, kann man sich überlegen,
künstliche Süssstoffe
als Ersatz zu verwenden.
Dort gibt es
noch ein paar offene Fragen.
Während man beim Zucker ganz klar
sagen kann, dass er schädlich ist,
ist man bei den künstlichen
Süssstoffen noch unsicher.
Es gibt noch
natürlich vorkommenden Zuckerersatz,
z.B. Stevia,
Birkenzucker oder Erythrit.
Das sind vom Profil her
wahrscheinlich günstigere Varianten.
Aber auch da
brauchen wir noch mehr Wissen.
Die muss man noch genau erforschen.
Noch eine vielleicht
überraschende Tatsache ist,
dass Konserven oft Zucker enthalten,
was man auch nicht erwarten würde.
In Essiggurken?
- Ja.
Das ist im Rahmen einer
normalen Ernährung kein Problem.
Man isst in der Regel
auch kein Kilogramm pro Tag.
Trotzdem ist es erstaunlich:
Es sind immerhin 5 g auf 100 g.
Da wird effektiv Zucker zugefügt.
- Als Geschmacksverstärker.
Zucker löst sehr viele Effekte
im Körper aus.
Mit dem,
was wir als Zucker bezeichnen,
ist meistens,
Haushaltszucker gemeint.
Dieser besteht aus zwei Teilen -
aus Fruchtzucker und Traubenzucker.
Das sind zwei Komplizen, die beide
negative Effekte im Körper haben,
die sich gegenseitig verstärken.
Der gewöhnliche,
weisse Haushaltszucker
wird aus Zuckerrüben
oder Zuckerrohr hergestellt.
Er besteht aus zwei Teilen.
Ein Teil ist Traubenzucker.
Der andere Teil ist Fruchtzucker.
Die beiden Teile werden vom Körper
unterschiedlich verarbeitet.
Traubenzucker wird mithilfe
des Hormons Insulin verwertet
und liefert unserem Körper
schnelle Energie.
Lässt die Wirkung nach,
wird im Hirn die Lust
nach mehr Süssem aktiviert.
Fruchtzucker muss zuerst in der Leber
aufgearbeitet werden,
bevor er von den Zellen als
Treibstoff verwendet werden kann.
Bei übermässigem Konsum wird die
Leber mit Fruchtzucker überschwemmt.
Der überschüssige Fruchtzucker
wird dann in Fett umgewandelt.
Zu viel Zucker kann zu Übergewicht
und Krankheiten wie Diabetes führen.
Bekannt ist das bei Leuten, die sehr
viele Süssgetränke konsumieren,
aber trotzdem noch schlank bleiben.
Es gibt auch Serien, in denen Kinder
beschrieben werden,
die bereits eine Fettleber haben.
Sie konsumieren
sehr viele Süssgetränke,
aber man sieht es ihnen nicht an.
Der grösste Teil des Zuckerbedarfs
wird in der Schweiz durch
den Anbau von Zuckerrüben gedeckt.
Rund 4'500 Bauern
pflanzen Zuckerrüben an.
Von der Aussaat Mitte März
bis zur Ernte Ende September
müssen die Rüben aufwendig kultiviert
und gepflegt werden.
Um 1 kg Zucker zu produzieren,
braucht man
zwischen 7 und über 10 m2 Land.
Und das ist ... äh ...
... trotzdem eine enorme Leistung
der Pflanze,
und es wird ein grosser Aufwand
betrieben,
wenn man
an den Ertrag denkt.
Dieses Feld umfasst rund 40'000 m2
und es sollte einen Ertrag
von rund 60 t Zucker geben.
Doch der Schweizer Zucker
hat ein Problem.
Ohne Subventionen
wäre unsere Zuckerproduktion
nicht konkurrenzfähig.
Zu gross ist der Preisdruck
aus dem Ausland.
Das Hauptproblem in der Schweiz ist
der tiefe Zuckerpreis.
Wir können nicht ein Jahr
die Produktion stoppen,
weil die Fabrik
eine gewisse Menge braucht.
Entweder produzieren wir genug
oder wir hören auf.
Nach der Ernte im Herbst
werden die Rüben
in den Zuckerfabriken Aarberg
oder Frauenfeld verarbeitet.
Drei Monate lang laufen dort
die Maschinen Tag und Nacht.
Zucker ist sicher wichtig
für die Wirtschaft.
Der grösste Abnehmer
von Schweizer Zucker ist Red Bull.
Sie brauchen
rund 25 % der Schweizer Ernte.
Die Lebensmittelhersteller, wollen
in ihren Produkten Schweizer Zucker.
Unser Zucker ist auch besser.
Von der Strukturierung,
der Körnung her
ist Schweizer Zucker
weltweit der beste Zucker.
* Akzentuierte Klänge *
Im Bundesamt für Lebensmittel-
sicherheit und Veterinärwesen in Bern
beschäftigt man sich von Amtes wegen
mit der Zuckerfrage.
Zucker ist kein Grundnahrungsmittel.
Zucker ist ein Lebensmittel.
Und das ist ...
Er ist kein Grundnahrungsmittel,
weil er
keine lebenswichtigen Nährstoffe
wie Vitamine und Mineralstoffe
enthält.
Zucker ist eigentlich
leere Kalorien.
Ob der Mensch Zucker braucht,
ist eine gute Frage.
Das führt zu viel Verwirrung.
Tatsächlich
gibt es im Körper Zellen,
die Zucker brauchen,
um Energie zu gewinnen.
Der Zucker muss aber nicht
mit der Nahrung aufgenommen werden.
Wir können ihn selber herstellen,
z.B. aus Eiweiss
oder Fett, das wir essen.
Oder aus komplexen Kohlenhydraten,
also Stärkeprodukten.
Wir müssen uns den Zucker
nicht über die Nahrung zuführen.
Wenn man sich überlegt, wie lange
der Mensch schon Zucker konsumiert,
macht das auch Sinn.
Der Mensch hat sich entwickelt -
es gibt ihn seit 400'000 Jahren.
Den Zucker haben wir erst seit
ca. 150 Jahren in unserer Nahrung -
in dieser Dimension.
Wenn wir den Zucker in der Nahrung
brauchen würden, hätten wir uns
die letzten 400'000 Jahre
nicht so gut entwickelt.
Auch die Müeslifabrik bio-familia
im Kanton Obwalden
verwendet in ihren Produkten
Schweizer Zucker.
Vor 60 Jahren wurde hier
nur Birchermüesli
für den Schweizer Markt hergestellt.
Heute liefert die Firma
Frühstücksflocken in die ganze Welt.
Für Produkte mit weniger Zucker
steigt die Nachfrage.
Das freut auch Niklaus Iten.
Der Lebensmittelingenieur
kämpft seit Jahren für eine Reduktion
von Zucker in Lebensmitteln.
Aber so einfach ist das gar nicht.
Man kann nicht plötzlich
den Zucker auf Null runtersenken.
Das funktioniert neurologisch nicht.
Das hat mit Neurochemie zu tun.
Die Leute würden sagen:
"Das schmeckt nach nichts."
"Ich nehme die Zuckerbomben, die
links und rechts im Regal stehen."
Damit ist niemandem geholfen.
Man muss sukzessive weniger Zucker
zuführen - Schritt für Schritt.
Dann gewöhnt man sich,
so wie ich das auch gemacht habe,
an eine weniger starke Süsse.
Und man hat dabei
den genau gleichen Genusseffekt.
Zucker ist auch für Bäcker
und Konditor Gfeller aus Döttingen
eine wichtige Zutat,
jedoch nicht um jeden Preis.
Eine Rüeblitorte enthält sicher
Rüebli, Haselnüsse, Mehl, Butter,
Eier, Milch,
etwas Backpulver und Zucker.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Ich glaube, man führt
den Konsumenten langsam dazu,
immer mehr Zucker zu konsumieren.
Und es ist natürlich einfach,
viel Zucker dazuzugeben.
So macht man die Kundschaft
wahrscheinlich fast abhängig davon.
Ich kann dazu ein Beispiel erzählen.
Mein Vater hat schon vor 50 Jahren
Fasnachtschüechli gemacht.
Wir haben sie bis vor fünf Jahren
nach demselben Rezept gemacht.
Sie wurden sehr oft gelobt -
bis vor fünf Jahren einmal
ein Kunde kam und sagte,
dass unsere Fasnachtschüechli zwar
gut, aber nicht süss genug seien.
Wir passten das Rezept an.
Letzten Endes fand ich,
dass es nicht an uns liegen kann,
sondern es ist die Industrie,
die mehr Zucker dazugibt.
Und wir ...
Bei uns gibt es seit fünf Jahren
keine Fasnachtschüechli mehr,
weil wir zu unseren Rezepten stehen.
Wir wollen sie beibehalten.
Sie müssen
nach unserem Gutdünken sein.
Man meint immer, wenn der Zucker
fehle, habe man keinen Genuss mehr.
Aber Genuss hat nichts damit zu tun,
seinen Körper mit diesem
weissen Zeug vollzumüllen.
Das ist eine reine Gewohnheitssache.
Wenn man sich
einmal daran gewöhnt hat,
treten wieder andere Geschmäcker
in den Vordergrund.
Man schmeckt Sachen,
die man wegen der enormen Süsse
nicht mehr geschmeckte.
Schritt für Schritt zurück.
Dafür brauchen wir entsprechende
politische Rahmenbedingungen.
Da muss gehandelt werden.
Eine Woche lang ist Familie Rech-
steiner nun ohne Zucker unterwegs.
Obwohl sich zuvor alle
intensiv mit dem Thema Zuckerentzug
auseinandergesetzt haben,
hält der Alltag
Überraschungen bereit.
Ihre Stimmungen und Erfahrungen
haben sie für uns
mit dem Handy festgehalten.
Anfang Woche hatte ich das Gefühl,
ich bekäme zu wenig zu Essen.
Ich hatte dieses befriedigende
Sättigungsgefühl nicht.
Ich hätte
den ganzen Tag essen können.
Wenn wir freitags ausnahmsweise zu
Hause assen, war es eine Gewohnheit,
danach jeweils
noch einen Keks zu essen.
Darauf zu verzichten,
fiel uns allen ein wenig schwer.
Die grösste Herausforderung
diese Woche war das Essen auswärts.
Was mache ich am Mittag?
Vietnamesisch, thaiwanesisch,
indisch, italienisch -
das liegt natürlich nicht drin.
Zucker ist wie eine Droge.
Ich versuche nun,  dem auszuweichen.
Also, man versucht automatisch
dem Zucker auszuweichen,
aber man findet einfach nichts.
Das ist ein wenig frustrierend.
Zucker hat tatsächlich
gewisse Eigenschaften,
die genau gleich sind
wie bei anderen Drogen.
Er stimuliert tatsächlich
dieselben Rezeptoren im Hirn
wie andere Drogen.
Er schafft auch
eine gewisse Abhängigkeit.
Das merken Leute,
die sehr viel Zucker konsumieren
und dann plötzlich nicht mehr.
Dann sehen sie überall nach,
ob sie eine Packung Kekse finden.
Sie bekommen Heisshungerattacken,
werden nervös und suchen.
Das sind auch
typische Eigenschaften.
Tabak ist ein Produkt, von dem
man weiss, dass es schädlich ist.
Zucker gehört zur Ernährung.
Bei der Ernährung
ist für uns besonders wichtig,
dass der Genuss
im Vordergrund steht.
Trotzdem muss man da
auch darauf achten,
dass man sich ausgewogen
und gesund ernährt.
Das ist für mich wirklich
ein grosser Unterschied
zwischen Tabak und Alkohol,
die süchtig machen,
und bei der Ernährung,
der Genuss im Vordergrund steht.
* Akzentuierte Klänge,
ergriffene Melodie *
* Einsetzen von gepfiffenem Lied *
* "In Holl I'll Be In Good Company"
von The Dead South *
Ich weiss nicht, ob es mit dem
Zuckerverzicht zusammenhängt.
Ich war gerade joggen
und fühle mich erstaunlich gut.
Ich habe weder Hunger
noch das Gefühl, ich wäre schwach.
Ich war
locker wie ein Reh unterwegs.
Jemand, der sich mehr bewegt,
kann nicht sagen,
dass er deswegen
mehr Zucker konsumieren darf.
Es gibt da sogar
relativ ungünstige Entwicklungen.
Es werden Tuben mit flüssigem Zucker
angepriesen, die man einnehmen kann.
Auch werden gewisse Sportlergetränke
propagiert,
die man beim Joggen trinken soll,
Das funktioniert nicht.
Die Behörden sagten der Bevölkerung
40 Jahre lang, was sie essen soll,
und, dass sie sich
v.a. mehr bewegen soll.
Beim Essen hiess es: weniger Fett.
Das war das Mantra.
Denn nicht der Zucker sei schuld
am zunehmendem Übergewicht
und den Herz-Kreislauf-Erkrankungen.
In einer 1967 in den USA publizierten
wissenschaftlichen Studie,
wurden Fett und Cholesterin
als die Übeltäter bezeichnet.
Zucker erlebte darauf
auch in Europa einen wahren Boom,
und die Zuckerindustrie unterstützte
den Imagewandel auch mit Werbespots.
(Originalton)
Zucker zaubert.
Zucker zaubert Energie.
Seht ihr? So gedeihen sie.
Zucker zaubert - nimm deshalb mehr.
Erst vor wenigen Jahren
konnte aufgedeckt werden,
dass die Zuckerindustrie die Studie
in Auftrag gegeben und bezahlt hatte.
Es ist v.a. die Geschichte,
des leider massiven Erfolgs
der Zuckerlobby.
Sie konnte mit den
genau gleichen Methoden und Taktiken
wie die Tabaklobby bewirken,
dass der Fokus weg vom Zucker
und hin zum Fett gelegt wurde.
Absolut verwerfliche Methoden.
Ach, wie wär das Leben hässlich,
gäbe es keinen Zucker mehr.
So ein hübsches, junges Mädchen
wäre dicklich, rund und schwer.
Zucker zaubert - ihre Linie
bleibt so schlank wie eine Pinie.
(Frau) Das lässt sich beweisen.
Zucker zaubert.
Wurde es besser?
Es wurde noch viel schlimmer.
Übergewicht nahm noch mehr zu -
und zwar rasant.
Die damit verbundenen Krankheiten,
die man dem Übergewicht anlastet,
haben auch zugenommen.
Fakt ist: Herz-Kreislauf-Erkrankungen
sind in der Schweiz die häufigsten
Todesursachen überhaupt.
Übergewicht und Diabetes erhöhen das
Risiko für eine solche Erkrankung.
Die Verfügbarkeit von Zucker erklärt
mehr ein Viertel der Anstieg
der Diabeteshäufigkeit
im vergangenen Jahrzehnt.
Und zwar bereinigt
um Alter und Adipositas.
Es ist also wirklich der Zucker,
der das bewirkt.
D.h. wiederum, wenn wir nichts tun,
dann steigt es so weiter.
Wenn wir etwas tun würden,
würde das bedeuten ...
Wir könnten pro Jahr und Kopf
1'000 Fr. einsparen,
wenn es uns gelingen würde,
den Zuckerkonsum wieder auf ein
normales, gesundes Level zu bringen.
Und das ohne Einbusse beim Genuss.
Das macht für eine vierköpfige
Familie 4'000 Fr. pro Jahr aus.
Ich behaupte,
das wäre locker möglich.
80 % der Schweizer Gesundheitskosten
werden durch nicht übertragbare
Krankheiten wie Diabetes,
Krebs oder Herz-Kreislauf-
Erkrankungen verursacht.
Durch einen gesünderen Lebensstil
mit weniger Zucker und weniger Salz
könnte mehr als die Hälfte
dieser Erkrankungen vermieden
oder zumindest verzögert werden.
Das hätte auch grosse Auswirkungen
auf die Gesundheitskosten.
Dazu bedarf es
einer Verhaltensänderung.
Verhaltensänderungen zeigen ...
Die gleiche Erfahrung
zeigte sich beim Salzkonsum.
Wir sprechen hier nicht von Jahren,
sondern von mehreren Jahrzehnten,
um den Zucker und den Salzkonsum
zu reduzieren. Das braucht Zeit.
"Hallo zusammen."
"Dass wir nun viel zu Hause sind,
macht die Challenge leichter."
"Um unsere Kochfantasie
zu beflügeln,
stöbern wir
vermehrt in den Kochbüchern."
"Die Einschränkungen
wegen des Zuckerverzichts
sind nicht sehr gross."
"Wir machen vieles selber -
Saucen, Hackbraten, Kräuterbutter,
Salatsaucen, etc."
"Und wir leben getreu dem Motto:
frisches Essen
und keine Fertigprodukte."
"Auch die Kinder
halten tapfer durch."
Heute hatte ich
grosse Lust auf Süsses.
Ich ging zum Kiosk.
Ich dachte,
ich müsse irgendetwas essen,
damit die Lust auf Süsses weggeht.
Der ganze Kiosk
besteht einfach aus Zucker!
Egal was man kauft,
überall ist Zucker drin.
Wenn die anderen beim Mittagstisch
gutes Essen haben
und wir nur Reis bekommen -
das ist schon scheisse.
Nach einer Woche
machten wir am Wochenende
einen grossen Fehler.
Wir machten Entenbrust
an einer süssen Sauce,
mit Orangen und Birkenzucker.
Der ist erlaubt.
Und das hat, zumindest bei mir,
unheimlich den Appetit angeregt.
Ich hatte am Abend
enormen Heisshunger.
Ich wusste nicht,
was ich machen sollte.
Dass ich beim Mittagstisch
nur Reis essen konnte,
weil sie nicht wussten,
ob im Riz Casimir Zucker ist,
hat mir bis jetzt als Einziges
nicht gefallen hat.
Spürst du beim Putzen,
dass du keinen Zucker im Körper hast?
Ich mache es deswegen
nicht mit mehr Freude,
aber ja, ich bin fit.
Er fehlt mir nicht für die Energie.
* Gemütliche Gitarrenklänge *
Im Wachstum ist man eigentlich
durch die Hormonlage
besonders empfindlich auf Zucker.
Man verträgt weniger Zucker.
Man kann aufzeigen, dass es
beim Zucker um eine Substanz geht,
die direkt
auf das Belohnungszentrum wirkt.
Deshalb funktioniert die
Selbstverantwortung per se nicht.
Ich glaube nicht, dass sich jemand
Gedanken darüber macht,
ob Zucker drin ist oder nicht. Man
trinkt es, weil man es gerne mag.
Egal ob die Eltern
daheim sind oder nicht:
Ich kenne niemanden,
der nur Wasser trinkt.
Süssgetränke sind ein grosses Thema.
Dort gibt es die grösste Datenmenge
darüber, wie schädlich Zucker ist.
Gerade die Süssgetränke
sind eine grosse Quelle.
Man kann in sehr kurzer Zeit,
sehr viel Zucker konsumieren.
Wenn man Zucker einsparen will,
zeigt
das Weglassen von Süssgetränken,
schnell den grössten Effekt.
Man kann zeigen, dass man den
Zuckerkonsum nur einschränken kann,
wenn man
die Verfügbarkeit einschränkt.
Es reicht nicht, auf
freiwillige Massnahmen zu setzen.
Leider reicht es nicht.
Weitergehende Massnahmen sind nötig.
Eine dieser Massnahmen wäre
die Einführung einer Zuckersteuer.
In anderen europäischen Ländern
wurde diese bereits umgesetzt -
gegen den Widerstand
der mächtigen Lebensmittel-
und Süssgetränke-Hersteller,
die einen Umsatzrückgang
befürchtet hatten.
In der Schweiz gab es
2018 im Parlament einen Vorstoss,
eine Zuckersteuer einzuführen.
Die Vorlage
hatte einen schweren Stand.
Braucht man in der Schweiz
eine Zuckersteuer?
Sicher nicht.
- Definitiv nicht.
Nein, das wäre eine Bevormundung.
- Freiwilligkeit ist immer besser.
Es ist nicht Sache des Staates,
zu entscheiden,
was die Kinder zu sich nehmen.
Das ist Sache der Eltern.
Kinder können
doch nicht selber entscheiden.
Die bekommen einen Batzen
von zu Hause oder nicht.
Wenn man sagt, sie sollen morgen
keine Cola trinken,
halten sie sich schon daran.
Die Voraussetzung
für Eigenverantwortung ist,
dass man Bescheid weiss.
Man muss wissen,
dass Zucker schädlich ist,
damit man selber entschieden kann,
ob man ihn konsumieren will.
Also sind ein Hinweis
und eine Schulung nötig.
Man müsste die Bevölkerung schulen,
damit ihr das bewusst ist.
Man müsste es
vielleicht sogar anschreiben.
So wie auf einer Bierflasche steht:
"Nicht gut für schwangere Frauen."
Oder: "Tabak kann zu Krebs führen."
Auf zuckerhaltigen Produkten müsste
stehen: "Schädigt die Gesundheit."
Wenn das gegeben ist,
aber nicht zu einer Reduktion führt,
dann muss man weiter gehen.
Eine Zuckersteuer auf Süssgetränke
würde ich sinnvoll finden.
In Grossbritannien
wurde 2018 im Kampf gegen
zu viel Zucker in Süssgetränken
eine Zuckersteuer eingeführt.
Mit grossem Erfolg. Viele Getränke
haben seither massiv weniger Zucker.
Ein halber Liter Schweppes hat
in England sechs Würfelzucker,
in der Schweiz sind es elf.
Knapp das Doppelte.
Oder Fanta - in Grossbritanien
kommen seit der Zuckersteuer
noch sechs Würfel
auf einen halben Liter.
In der Schweiz
sind es ganze 13 Stück.
Es gibt momentan eine Tendenz,
dass Erfrischungsgetränke,
aber auch andere Nahrungsmittel,
die Zucker enthalten,
für alles
verantwortlich gemacht werden,
was mit Übergewicht zu tun hat.
Wir sind der Meinung,
dass das sehr einseitig ist.
Ist Zucker gesund oder ungesund?
Zucker ist sicher nicht ungesund.
Aber zu viel Zucker -
das ist ungesund.
Aber es liegt in der Verantwortung
jedes einzelnen,
selber zu entscheiden,
wie viel Zucker er isst.
Sie lobbyieren
für die Lebensmittelindustrie.
Sie wehren sich
gegen schärfere Auflagen.
Ich als Liberale
setze mich für Arbeitsplätze ein.
Die Nahrungsmittelindustrie
in der Schweiz
beinhaltet
viele Tausende Arbeitsplätze.
Das ist auch eine Möglichkeit
für unsere Schweizer Bauern,
ihre Produkte zu verkaufen.
Es ist ein riesiger Markt,
das muss man wissen.
Sehr viele sind daran beteiligt -
vom Zuckerrübenbauern
bis zur Lebensmittelindustrie.
Da gibt es viele Interessen.
Da ist der freiwillige Ansatz
zur Reduktion von Zucker.
Gibt es im Parlament
so etwas wie eine Zuckerlobby?
Ja, das würde ich sagen.
Wir haben Vertreter
von CHOCO- und BISCOSUISSE.
Wir haben die Interessengemein-
schaft Mineralwasser und Softdrinks.
Es gibt verschiedene Gruppen,
die sie vertreten.
Der Vorstoss, in der Schweiz
eine Zuckersteuer einzuführen,
wurde im Parlament
mit grosser Mehrheit abgelehnt.
Die Schweiz geht einen anderen Weg.
An der Weltausstellung Expo 2015
in Mailand
unterzeichnete Bundesrat Alain Berset
zusammen mit zehn Schweizer Firmen,
darunter Migros, Coop und Nestlé,
einen Vertrag,
der auf Freiwilligkeit basiert.
Mit der sog. Erklärung von Mailand
verpflichten sich die Firmen,
die Rezepturen ihrer Produkte
zu überprüfen
und den Zuckergehalt im Joghurt
und in Frühstückszerealien
schrittweise zu reduzieren.
Wo steht die Schweiz heute?
Wir haben erreicht,
dass der Zuckergehalt
in den Frühstückszerealien
durchschnittlich
um 13 % reduziert wurde,
und bei den Joghurts um 3,5 %.
Als Erstes muss man sich fragen:
Ist das überhaupt die
Zucker-Hauptquelle in der Schweiz?
Konsumieren wir wirklich den meisten
Zucker über Müesli und Joghurt?
Ich glaube nicht. Das ist wahr-
scheinlich ein sehr kleiner Teil.
Das Zweite ist: Wie viel Zucker
wird eigentlich eingespart?
Wenn man von 3-10 % spricht,
dann ist das ein halber Zuckerwürfel
pro Joghurtbecher.
Das ist verschwindend klein.
Für mich ist die Deklaration
von Mailand ungenügend.
Das sind nicht die Produkte, die man
wirklich einschränken sollte.
Und die Einschränkung an sich
ist auch viel zu gering.
Ich würde den Fokus
auf Süssgetränke legen.
Ich würde den Fokus auf Verbote
von Werbung an Kinder legen.
Ich würde auch schauen,
dass man bei den Kassen,
Die Regale auf Augenhöhe von Kindern
mit Zuckerhaltigem entfernt.
Das wäre eine Massnahme,
die ich vorschlagen würde.
Da sind wir wirklich
beim Thema Werbung, Marketing.
Kinder sind sehr empfänglich
für Werbung und das ist ein Problem.
Das ist eine Tatsache.
Man sieht auch,
dass sie Übergewichtszahlen
bei Kindern relativ hoch sind,
in der Schweiz
weniger hoch als im Ausland.
Aber wir haben
ein Problem bei den Kindern.
* Akzentuierte Klänge *
Ich muss sagen, die letzten paar
Tage fielen mir am schwersten.
Das habe ich nicht erwartet.
Ich dachte, es würde
am Anfang des Monats schwierig sein.
Aber wir sind jetzt in der Mitte,
und es fiel mir extrem schwer,
auf Süssigkeiten zu verzichten.
Besonders schwierig finde ich es,
wenn ich nichts zu tun habe,
wenn ich zu Hause bin
und lernen muss.
Dann bekomme ich
Lust auf etwas Süsses.
Das finde ich sehr schwierig.
Der Heisshunger
der ersten zwei Wochen ist weg.
Ich habe nach dem Essen nicht mehr
das Gefühl, dass ich nicht satt bin.
Ich habe nur festgestellt, dass ich
etwas früher schlafen gehe.
Ich glaube,
es ist mir in der Stube langweilig,
wenn ich nicht
in eine Keksdose greifen kann.
Sibylle arbeitet in einem Alters-
und Pflegezentrum in Bad Zurzach.
Darf ich wieder hinaufgehen.
- Ja.
Dann gehen wir nach Hause.
Eins, zwei, drei.
Jetzt gehen wir zum Lift.
Zum Lift?
- Genau.
Also gut.
Sibylle hat das Glück,
dass sie am Arbeitsort essen kann.
In einer Küche, die auch für
spezielle Diäten eingerichtet ist.
So, nun haben wir es geschafft.
In der Grossküche des Heims
werden die Mahlzeiten
täglich frisch zubereitet.
Ganz auf Zucker verzichten,
das kann und will man nicht.
Zucker spielt beim Kochen
eine sehr grosse Rolle.
Man kann mit ihm Wasser entziehen,
Sachen stabilisieren,
weil das Wasser entzogen wird.
Ausserdem ist Süsse
auch ein sehr wichtiger Rohstoff.
Wenn wir ausweichen
und den Zucker weglassen,
ist eine entsprechende Anpassung
schwierig.
Gerade bei Kuchen
oder solchen Dingen
enthält Zucker
Stabilisatoren-Bestandteile.
Sonst muss man
andere Rezepturen verwenden,
weil sonst ein Kuchen
kein Kuchen wird.
Hallo, Sibylle.
- Hallo.
Ich sehe, dass du Hunger hast.
Ja, es sieht gut aus.
- Super.
Kann ich dir irgendwelche
Informationen geben?
Schaust du auf etwas Spezielles?
- Ich brauche etwas ohne Zucker.
Hast du da ...
- Sicher.
Von den Stärkebeilagen kann ich dir
den zuckerfreien Reis empfehlen.
Das ist Pouletgeschnetzeltes.
Das enthält auch keinen Zucker.
Das ist sehr gut. Danke schön.
- En Guete.
Danke, dir dann auch.
Hier im Betrieb kann ich relativ gut
auf Zucker verzichten.
In Restaurants ist es schwieriger,
weil man nie genau weiss,
welche Fertigprodukte
es im Essen hat.
Dort muss man immer nachfragen.
Esther, hier steht ein Fladen.
Wir verzichten doch
diese Woche auch noch auf Zucker.
Ich habe mir Mühe gegeben,
ihn ohne Zucker zu machen.
Wir mögen sehr gerne Fladen.
Ich hatte wieder einmal Lust darauf.
Statt wie sonst Vanillezucker,
habe ich einen Teelöffel Erythrit
dazugegeben.
Das ist uns erlaubt.
Bis jetzt habe ich noch keine
negativen Meldungen dazu bekommen.
Ich probiere dann auch ein Stück.
Wir haben heute den 22. Tag,
den letzten Sonntag ohne Zucker.
Ich freue mich,
wenn ich wieder Zopf essen kann.
Den vermisse ich wirklich etwas.
Ich ging heute zum ersten Mal seit
Ewigkeiten wieder einmal einkaufen.
Und als ich am Kühler
mit diesen Kaffeebechern
vorbeigegangen bin,
fiel es mir extrem schwer,
keinen zu nehmen.
Ich hatte extrem Lust darauf.
Wir sind jetzt fast
am Ende dieser Zucker-Challenge.
Es steht uns noch eine Woche bevor.
Es ging bis jetzt gut.
Ich hoffe, die letzte Woche
geht auch noch gut.
Wir haben noch eine Woche vor uns.
Ich bin sehr zuversichtlich,
dass wir auch diese Woche
noch gut durchhalten.
Felix Lösch
arbeitet als ganzheitlicher
Gesundheitsberater in Winterthur.
Er lebt seit bald zehn Jahren
konsequent ohne industriell
hergestellten Zucker.
Bemerkt er einen Unterschied?
Das hat eine grosse Wirkung. Ich bin
seither z.B. kaum mehr krank.
Ich kann an einer Hand abzählen,
wie oft ich krank geworden bin.
Und wenn ich
z.B. eine Erkältung habe ...
Früher dauerte sie ca. eine Woche
bis ich wieder gesund war,
manchmal auch zwei.
Heute ist das
eine Sache von Stunden.
D.h, mein Immunsystem ist
in der Lage, effektiv zu arbeiten.
Ein Teil ist darauf zurückzuführen,
dass ich keinen industriell
hergestellten Zucker mehr esse.
* Klingel *
Hallo, herzlich willkommen.
Ich heisse Felix.- Antonia.
Esther, hallo.
Du bist Raphael. Freut mich.
Kommt herein.
Ich heisse euch herzlich willkommen
zum Schokoladekurs.
Die Schokolade, die wir herstellen,
besteht nur
aus natürlichen Inhaltsstoffen.
Ich unterscheide konsequent
zwischen natürlichem Zucker
und industriell erzeugtem Zucker.
Natürlicher Zucker ist der Zucker,
der z.B. in einem Apfel ist.
Ihr wisst alle,
ein Apfel schmeckt süss.
Er enthält verschiedene Zuckerarten.
Der Apfel, den man vom Baum pflückt,
hat alle Vitalstoffe,
die unser Körper braucht,
um die Zuckerstoffe, die der Apfel
enthält, verarbeiten zu können.
Wenn wir aber industriell
hergestellten Zucker haben,
dann enthält dieses Isolat, dieser
industriell hergestellter Zucker,
die Vitalstoffe nicht mehr.
Und die fehlen dann unserem Körper,
damit er
den Zucker verarbeiten kann.
Wenn man die Schokolade
richtig temperieren will,
und das wollen wir ...
Die Schokolade
macht nämlich genau das:
Sie hat diesen Effekt - sie knackt.
* Dynamische Klänge *
Muss man sie überhaupt süssen
oder könnte man vollkommen
auf den Zucker verzichten?
Man könnte auf Zucker verzichten.
Sie wäre dann einfach recht herb.
* Dynamische Musik *
Weil die Schokolade
mit Honig gesüsst wurde,
werden die Rechsteiners
sie erst degustieren,
wenn die Zucker-Challenge
abgeschlossen ist.
"Liebe Redaktion."
"Die Challenge ging gestern
mit der Blutentnahme
bei Frau Wölnerhanssen zu Ende."
"Wir sind
mit dem Erreichten sehr zufrieden."
"Und wir haben uns vorgenommen,
nicht wieder in die alten
Gewohnheiten zurückzufallen."
"Wir sind ganz gespannt
auf die Laborresultate."
"Herzliche Grüsse."
"Familie Rechsteiner."
Ich habe die Blutwerte
und die Auswertung bekommen.
Es sind vier Wochen vergangen.
Ich bin extrem überrascht.
Ich habe das nicht so erwartet.
Ich dachte, es gebe vielleicht einen
geringen Effekt, wenn überhaupt
Ich dachte, die vier Wochen
seien ein wenig kurz.
Aber es haben wirklich alle
in dieser Familie profitiert.
Sie haben alle
einen Gewichtsverlust.
Sie haben eine Verbesserung
des Blutzuckerwerts.
Auch der Insulinwert ist besser.
Die Blutfette sind besser.
Der Unterschied
ist also erstaunlich gross,
also wirklich erstaunlich gross.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Hallo, Raphael.
Zum Abschluss der Zucker-Challenge
hat Raphael beim Dorfkonditor
eine Rüeblitorte
mit reduziertem Zucker bestellt.
Einen schönen Tag.
- Tschau, danke.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Oh, habt ihr Hunger?
- (Alle) Ja.
Heute gibt es eine Sauce,
die Zucker enthält.
En Guete.
- En Guete.
Wir hatten
schon lange kein Curry mehr.
Das Fazit dieser vier Wochen
Zucker-Challenge ist:
Es macht wirklich Sinn,
Zucker zu reduzieren.
Es war eine Herausforderung,
aber ich würde es wieder tun.
Es war eine gute Erfahrung.
Ich empfehle jedem,
einmal so etwas zu machen.
Ich habe ca. 4,5 kg verloren.
Und das in vier Wochen.
Das ist schon fast dramatisch.
Ich habe abgenommen
und ich fühle mich auch fit.
Ich habe wirklich
positive Erlebnisse.
Ich habe nicht mehr
so grossen Hunger.
Es hat mich erstaunt, dass sich
der Körper umstellt, runterfährt,
und gar nicht mehr
nach Nahrung verlangt,
die er eigentlich nicht braucht.
Ich habe
noch eine kleine Überraschung.
Das Stück Rüeblitorte, das ich
heute bekam, fand ich extrem gut.
Früher hätte ich locker
ein zweites Stück gegessen.
Aber jetzt genügt es,
ich brauche nicht mehr.
Wer möchte einen Viertel?
* Alle lachen. *
Du bist nicht Obelix.
In diesen vier Wochen
fiel mir ein paar Mal auf:
Dinge, die ich
als gar nicht süss empfand,
schmeckten plötzlich extrem süss.
Einmal trank ich ein Glas Milch -
ich fand sie megasüss.
Marzipan ist mir jetzt
eindeutig zu süss.
Da sind sicher Aargauer Rüebli drin.
Wenn jemand das auch machen möchte,
würde ich als Tipp geben,
dass er es nicht alleine macht.
Will man vor dem Fernseher
etwas essen, was man nicht darf,
soll man schlafen gehen.
Ja.
Einen Monat lang
konnte Familie Rechsteiner
dem Zucker erfolgreich widerstehen.
Doch die eigentliche Challenge
beginnt jetzt im Alltag.
Zucker ist omnipräsent.
Eine Zuckersteuer
oder Werbebeschränkungen
wären Möglichkeiten,
den Zuckerverbrauch zu reduzieren.
Doch die Politik setzt auf
die Freiwilligkeit der Produzenten
und die Eigenverantwortung
der Konsumenten.
Kann Familie Rechsteiner
ihre guten Vorsätze umsetzen?
Wer gewinnt die Herausforderung?
Die Eigenverantwortung
oder die Droge Zucker?
Die Vorsätze
haben sich etwas verwässert.
Z.T. recht stark.
Ich bin schon wieder etwas ...
... in alte Gewohnheiten gefallen.
Wir haben wieder Guetzli zu Hause.
Ich esse ab und zu
ein Eis mit Kollegen.
ich könnte wieder
etwas mehr darauf achten.
Nach einem Monat lief es gut.
Nach drei Wochen
ist man daran gewöhnt, dann läuft's.
Aber um das durchzuziehen, muss man
den inneren Schweinehund überwinden.
Es ist extrem schwierig.
Es gibt immer wieder Versuchungen.
Und dann ist es passiert.
Dann ist man wieder
bei den alten Gewohnheiten,
wie vor der Zucker-Challenge.
Die Erfahrung
möchte ich nicht missen,
denn es hat uns aufgezeigt,
was Zucker mit uns macht.
Ich habe mich gut gefühlt.
Ich habe am Schluss
eigentlich nichts mehr vermisst.
Ich hätte nicht mehr
damit anfangen sollen.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
Liz Lei - 2021